father Abraham how many sons what what
many sons of father Abraham I am one of
them and so are you but Jesus loves me
more hey what is going on YouTube
another day another article you guys
keep killing it with this shite and as
mentioned before a hundred thousand
times you guys know this video is going
to have limited ads because they tryna
censor me so if you guys like this raw
unadulterated [ __ ] booty hole Ross
style videos oh that's not it either but
I'm just gonna stick with this stick
with it check out the patreon if you
can't support on the patreon it's okay I
still love you explain so for today's
user submitted article this this one's
kind of old I heard I heard it happened
last year but man tourists could become
a quadruple amputee after developing
flesh-eating infection from a spider
love if you go on to read the article
apparently this man went to go on
vacation to visit family and my god
there's a high possibility or a chance
that he might have gotten bit by a
spider that caused a necrotizing
arachnid disarmed know what that
basically means is that he got bit by a
spider that could have been the catalyst
for him to develop a flesh-eating
disease
and guess what country the sweet man was
visiting Australia you see this is why I
don't go there you have beautiful
beaches beautiful women amazing food and
after all that you got spiders that eat
babies missing I saw of videos for a
spider ate a mother [ __ ] bird Jesus
Christ you see this is why I don't [ __ ]
with spiders man and I gotta say people
say some of the dumbest things about
these apocalyptic creatures of doom they
are more scared of you than you are of
Bale's Oh says who
I study spiders my whole life oh really
[ __ ] you get home I don't understand
why people like to tell us folks who
have a rational fear of creatures that
can [ __ ] us up that they are more scared
of us than we are
what are you the Cesar Millan of the
spider world can you talk to them you
have to express your dummy
onda spider itch just listen you a RAC
naho unless you've had a one-on-one
conversation with the spider about this
[ __ ] feelings you did not
dominate dared me to [ __ ] these
[ __ ] shoot semen out of their
butt hole to create homes and they bite
[ __ ] and suck their spirit out
their body that is not the work of the
Lord that is the work of the devil
Jesus done created many creatures in
this world but Satan had his hand when
he created spiders hallelujah let me
tell you something it's a sight
well David we also have dogs as pets and
they bite people all the time you ever
see a puppy [ __ ] you gonna blame a
puppy puppies are cute dogs lick you
they wag their tail cuz they're happy
when they see you they have signs of
love and affection that you can clearly
see with your eyes how you gonna tell
what the spider loves you hmm can't do
it can you you've new serial killer and
this message to also goes for the same
with Sean sharks uh don't be afraid of
sharks David they're beautiful
prehistoric creatures they're scared of
you as well how would you know this
[ __ ] pop out the water look at
you was saying oh no that's a human I'm
so scared you know what I look like in
ocean water I look like a seal that has
given up on life that's a free meal for
a great white shark buffet and by the
way I'm not saying anybody out there on
purpose should ever kill a shark they
are beautiful
prehistoric creatures from a distance
you know what sharks are called in
Korean they're called is water rapists
or that right they're like a pet cheetah
tears and like a shark you know you just
talk about sharks like they're having
underwater PTSD therapy sessions about
the humans they saw swimming around in
the water oh my god
I saw this fat Korean [ __ ] in
the water and he scared the living [ __ ]
out of me baby I don't want sharks dead
I love those things from a distance like
how am I not supposed to be scared of a
creature that could smell a drop of
blood in the water from 4,000 miles away
huh well I must be a shark too cuz I can
smell fried chicken from about three
miles away all I can say is I hope this
man survived this ordeal and I got to
tell you people maybe I'll visit
Australia one day but I'll tell you this
man y'all y'all need to fix your spider
situation okay but [ __ ] that [ __ ] I
heard your spiders also prey on Japanese
tourists and [ __ ] goddamnit well guys
thanks for that submitted article and I
will see you guys
next time shallots my Cambodian people
that me find those [ __ ] up in
the forest see y'all next time peace Oh
God
hope y'all liked that video I told y'all
I could talk about any chain you want me
to talk what am i doing yes everybody
I'm telling you I'm making regular
content and it feels good to make you
guys laugh and think about [ __ ] during
the [ __ ] week remember you guys
can submit topics talk about [ __ ] in the
comments and give me suggestions and
I'll write that down maybe I'll go up on
the podcast etc etc etcetera but let's
keep you guys involved so I will see you
guys next time make sure that you stop
by the patreon if you want to keep this
channel uncensored with some real ass
topics because I ain't trying to do that
Betty Boop [ __ ] you thought shaker see
y'all next time
we here at vegan Dale yo this [ __ ]
festival is hoppin there are so many
[ __ ] vendors here I think that of all
the festival that we've been to this has
been the biggest festival that we've
ever attended as with food that I'm not
that interested until the people right
next to me actually have a bucket of
vegan fried chicken
they have jambalaya and all the weird
mac and cheese [ __ ] but we're gonna get
ready to shoot and this is basically how
the shoot work screen we meet at the
location